fremde
[Musik]
oh mein Gott, jetzt werde ich dieses beschämende
Geständnis machen
dreifach gefalteter Burger dreifacher
Cheeseburger Ja,
ich weiß, dass es mir praktisch verboten ist,
denn als ich das meinem Diabetes-
Arzt erzählte, sagte er mir, dass es Dinge gibt, die Sie
nicht essen sollten,
aber es gibt  sind Dinge, von denen man nicht einmal
träumen sollte, sie zu essen, und
Triple-Street-Burger ist einer davon
[Musik]
Ich mag es nicht einmal, an Utopien zu denken,
denn wenn es eine Lektion des 20.
Jahrhunderts gibt, dann ist es egal, wie gut sie gemeint
waren
All die Utopien sind, denke ich,
alle Utopien verwandeln sich in
einen Albtraum, wenn sie verwirklicht werden. Ich denke, die
wahren Veränderungen sind
heute keine großen neuen Visionen, sondern Sie tun
etwas Kleines, und
wenn Sie dem folgen wollen,
müssen Sie mehr und mehr und alles tun  auf einmal
änderst du die gesellschaft aber ich glaube nicht
an große utopische visionen schriftsteller
besuch die uniform vom
hof langes
haus bekannter hof blick ist sehr komplex ich
kann nur pauschal antworten
ich bin von natur aus
äh pessimist  Denn nur so
können Sie Ihre Hoffnung offen halten, dass
fast etwas Gutes kommt, wenn
Sie ein Optimist sind,
weil die Dinge meistens schlecht werden, werden Sie die
ganze Zeit und alle Entscheidungen treffen,
aber wenn Sie ein Pessimismus sind, passiert von Zeit zu
Zeit etwas Schönes und es ist  Der
einzige Weg, um von Zeit zu Zeit fröhlich zu sein
[Musik]
Ich mag es nicht Ich hasse
jede tiefere Wahrheit in mir, weil ich denke,
wenn du tief in dich hineinschaust, was entdeckst
du, dass du voller Scheiße bist,
wir alle sind ich denke Authentizität  ist nicht
marlon brando dieser authentische schauspieler
weinen authentizität ist voll annehmen deine
maske
wie stehe ich zum
pazifismus pazifismus du weißt das problem
ist das
manchmal
den pazifismus aufzugeben und sogar mit waffen zu widerstehen
ist der einzige weg um den frieden zu wahren
das ist das paradoxon das wir haben müssen
Akzeptiere
also in diesem Sinne nicht, dass ich Kriegssorgen mag,
muss ein Alptraum sein,
aber es gibt hier ein Paradoxon, dass
Patifismus in der Regel perfekt
den Aggressoren dient, was wollen die
Russen in der Ukraine, seien wir fran  k
in einem aufrichtigen sinne wollen sie frieden
frieden unter ihrer besatzung und so weiter
was wollte deutschland 1940 in frankreich,
als es es besetzte frieden zweifellos
was will israel am westjordanland
frieden um es friedlich zu kontrollieren sie wissen
also da ist etwas
zutiefst falsch  falsch im pazifismus für mich
naja die musik hurst du und
ich bin ein alter rockkonservativer
für mich
passieren alle wirklich tollen dinge zwischen
65 und 75 mehr oder weniger
so
abgesehen von ramstein deren spezialfall
das ich gerne höre immer klassik
i  Ich bin eine absolute Wagner-
Ehre, aber aber
wenn Sie mir diese klassische
Frage stellen würden, gehen Sie bis zu Ihrem Tod auf eine Insel,
welche eine Komposition Sie nehmen werden
,
Arnold Schenberg
Leader,
es ist etwas absolut Einzigartiges, weil
es eine
Art
Oratorium von äh
eins
fast zwei ist  Stunden
romantische Geschichte, aber dann bewegt es sich in
seltsame Bereiche der Modernität des Frühlings
und so weiter, so dass dieser Übergang von
spuckender romantischer ultra-vagnerianer zu sprezzank
atonaler Moderne ist  In ein
und demselben in einem Schlag umgesetzt, das ist mein
absoluter Lieblings-Superhelden-Autor.
Ihre aktuelle Buchdesign-Philosophie
ist riskant, aber ich werde versuchen zu antworten, okay,
wir haben normalerweise positive Metaphysik,
wo Sie sagen, dass es einen höchsten
Wesensgott gibt,
die universelle Struktur der Realität oder
Sie
Den radikalsten in diesem Raum-Buddhismus
haben Sie, dass Sie
eine ursprüngliche Leere haben und dann durch diese
Störung der Leere Dinge auftauchen,
aber sie kehren zu Staub zurück und so weiter.
Meine spontane Ontologie ist, dass selbst
die Leere nicht am Anfang am
Anfang steht  Einige schreckliche Katastrophen
Dinge gehen schief
Es gibt keinen Anfang Dinge sind
von Anfang an Thron der Schiene
und dass das, was der Buddhismus
zu dieser ursprünglichen Leere des Nirvana zurückbringen will, immer
eine rückwirkende Illusion ist, also ist es eine zutiefst
pessimistische Theologie. Ja, es gibt einen Sturz,
aber da  ist nichts vor dem Fall
[Musik]